salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
aujourd'hui on va parler faits divers je
vous rassure rien ne sordide trois
arnaques vous allez le voir plus c'est
gros plus ça passe comment la Tour
Eiffel a été vendue en pièce détachées
comment des greffes d'organes très
spécial ont été promises à des patients
pour augmenter leur virilité et enfin
comment une femme a réussi à se faire
passer pour Jeanne d'Arc pour cela je
suis accompagné par David Chemla et ça
ce n'est pas une énigme vous l'avez déjà
vu sur le compte Tik Tok epicurieux
on commence à Paris avec une affaire qui
s'est déroulée il y a un tout petit peu
moins d'un siècle voici l'histoire de
Victor Lustig un arnaqueur de haut vol
qui a réussi à vendre la Tour Eiffel
en pièce détachées pas celle-ci la vraie
nous sommes en 1925 36 ans après son
inauguration la dame de fer n'a plus
trop la cote souvenez-vous qu'à
l'origine il était même question de la
démonter juste après l'Exposition
universelle de 1889 et bien disons
qu'elle ne fait toujours pas l'unanimité
elle commence à rouiller et son
entretien coûte extrêmement cher à la
mairie de Paris qui en est devenu
propriétaire quant à Gustave Eiffel son
créateur il n'est plus là pour tenter de
la rendre indispensable avec des
expériences scientifiques puisqu’il est
mort bref on sait plus trop quoi en
faire mais Victor Lustig lui il a bien
une idée il est autrichien et c'est un
parfait escroc il a été proxénète avant
de plumer de riches vieilles dames sur
les paquebots lors des croisières
transatlantiques mais cette fois luftig
a mis la barre très haut il veut vendre
la Tour Eiffel en pièce détaché aussi
dingue que cela puisse nous paraître à
l'époque ça choque personne en effet
nous sommes au lendemain de la Première
Guerre mondiale et la France a besoin
d'acier pour se reconstruire or il se
trouve que la Tour Eiffel est construite
en acier en faire plus de lait
précisément 7300 tonnes si la dame de
fer ne sert plus à rien pourquoi ne pas
aller puiser dans cette manne reste plus
qu'à mettre au point l'escroquerie et
autant dire que Victor est sacrément
gonflé il se procure des faux papiers et
se fait passer pour un haut
fonctionnaire mandaté par la Ville de
Paris puis il invite dans le prestigieux
hôtel de crayon 5 des plus grands
ferrailleurs de la capitale parmi eux
lustiga ferait un gros poisson qui
s'appelle justement André poisson ça
s'invente pas après une visite privée en
haut de la tour Eiffel ce pauvre poisson
mort à l'hameçon lu stigle lui promet de
lui lâcher les 15000 poutres et les
millions de pièces métalliques de la
tour en échange d'un gros chèque et d'un
joli pot de vin évidemment quand la
victime se rend compte de l'arnaque il
est déjà trop tard le chèque a été
encaissé et ludique est déjà loin à ce
stade évidemment on a tous envie de
savoir combien valait la Tour Eiffel en
1925 alors David combien mais bon non
c'est rien car notre poisson pigeon a eu
tellement honte qu'il n'a osé le dire à
personne Victor le style a réussi
l'escroquerie parfaite le problème c'est
qu'il est un peu trop gourmand quelques
années plus tard il retente le coup mais
cette fois il se fait démasquer et doit
s'exiler aux États-Unis là il aurait pu
se mettre ouvert et se faire oublier
mais non il fait encore plus fort il
décide d'escroquer la paie le Styx
s'attaque au plus redoutable de tous Al
Capone le parrain de la mafia Chicago il
lui promet de doubler son capital contre
50000 dollars marcher conclu mais Capone
se rend vite compte qu'il a à faire à un
escroc toutefois bluffé par son culot le
mafieux ne lui en tient pas rigueur il
lui aurait même pardonné et aurait
assuré sa protection en prison car oui
notre célèbre escroc c'est finalement
fait arrêter en 1935 pour une histoire
de faux billets il est alors condamné à
15 ans de détention
dans la terrible prison d'Alcatraz
l'histoire suivante est complètement
surréaliste les plus grands scénaristes
auraient eu mal à l'inventer ou prétexte
de booster la virilité de ces patients
un pseudo chirurgien américain réussi à
les convaincre de se faire greffer des
testicules de boucles non vous ne rêvez
pas John Romulus John Romulus bringler
n'est pas médecin mais il a toujours
voulu le devenir sauf qu'il n'a ni les
compétences ni l'argent nécessaire pour
suivre de grandes études qu'à cela
tienne emportée par sa passion il achète
dans les années 1910 de faux permis
d'exercer la médecine c'est ainsi qu'il
ouvre une pharmacie et se constitue une
fidèle clientèle quelques années plus
tard lorsqu’un fermier du Kansas se
plant d’impuissance sexuelle il se rend
tout naturellement chez lui bringley lui
fait alors une drôle de proposition il
suggère de lui transplanter des
testicules de boucs l'animal est connu
pour être un symbole de virilité en
raison de son fort taux de testostérone
le patient accepte au bout de quelques
semaines son épouse annonce être
enceinte bon elle était évidemment
auparavant ou bien le père n'est pas
celui qu'on pense toujours est-il
qu'aussitôt le succès est attribué à
l'intervention chirurgicale du médecin
dès lors il acquiert une solide
réputation et multiplie les
interventions du même type il ouvre même
une clinique l'intervention est facturée
entre 750 et 1500 dollars suivant la
qualité du greffon mais rien en revanche
aucun commentaire sur les graves
complications et les décès postes
opératoires pourquoi ce silence pourquoi
le faux médecin n'est-il pas inquiété en
fait il faut se remettre dans le
contexte de l'époque en 1918 la médecine
ignore tous des mécanismes de rejet qui
se produisent en cas de transplantation
d'organes mais bon on aurait quand même
pu s'inquiéter sauf qu'au même moment
d'autres pathologies font des ravages
aux États-Unis c'est le cas de la grippe
espagnole beaucoup de médecins refusent
de sculpter les patients victimes
d'injection de crainte d'être même
contaminé ce qui n'est pas le cas de
Brinkley qui lui accepte de les recevoir
grâce à ses greffes Romulus Brinkley
gagne jusqu'à 15 dollars par semaine
pardonnez-moi l'expression mais là on
peut dire qu'il se fait de véritables on
vante même ses exploits jusqu'à
Hollywood où il est invité en grande
pompe par le très puissant patron du Los
Angeles ce dernier consacre de nombreux
articles à la succès story du magicien
qui guérit les pannes sexuelles Romulus
bringley devient une véritable star pour
attirer toujours plus de patience il
lance en 1923 sa propre station de radio
tous les soirs entre deux morceaux de
jazz le faux médecin répond aux
auditeurs et fait la promotion de ses
miraculeuses transplantations sauf qu'à
force de se mettre en avant ron lui
attire de plus en plus les soupçons en
1930 le vent tourne on l'accuse de
fraude et de charlatanisme c'est faux
diplômes sont publiés dans la presse et
l'Ordre des médecins du Kansas lui
retire sa licence qu'importe bringley
contourne l'interdiction en embauchant
de vrais chirurgiens qui poursuivent les
opérations et comme il n'a peur de rien
il se présente comme candidat au poste
de gouverneur du Kansas il perd mais
recueille tout de même 30% des en 1932
il s'installe au Texas où il ouvre un
nouvel hôpital l'histoire se répète et
personne ne semble pouvoir l'arrêter ce
n'est que des années plus tard qu'il est
finalement poursuivi par le gouvernement
fédéral américain pour faute
professionnelle des centaines de
victimes portent pleines et lui réclame
d'énormes des dommagesment bringley
échappe à la prison mais se retrouve
complètement ruiné il meurt en 1942
d'une crise cardiaque en 16 ans on
estime à 5000 le nombre de victimes ne
ce qui est considéré aujourd'hui comme
la plus grande escroquerie médicale du
20e siècle nous allons maintenant faire
un énorme bon dans le temps l'histoire
suivante débute en 1436 voilà 5 ans que
Jeanne d'Arc est passé de vie à trépas
sur le bûcher quand une rumeur
complètement folle se répand dans le
royaume la Pucelle d'Orléans serait
toujours en vie mais comment est-ce
possible le 30 mai 1431 à Rouen ils
étaient des centaines à assister à son
supplice dans les flammes sous le regard
des Anglais qui ont ensuite jeté ces
cendres dans la pourtant cinq ans plus
tard dans un petit village près de Metz
une jeune femme l'affirme haut et fort
Jeanne d'Arc est en vie et pour cause et
elle le jure Jeanne d'Arc c'est elle il
faut le reconnaître elle ressemble
beaucoup à la Pucelle elle a la
vingtaine une petite taille et une coupe
au bol pour certains nostalgiques de
Jeanne d'Arc c'est suffisant pour y
croire mais cela ne résout pas un
problème majeur si cette fille est bien
Jeanne d'Arc qui était celle qui a brûlé
sur le bûcher une usurpatrice ou bien la
vraie qui a finalement ressuscité face à
toutes ces questions la nouvelle Jeanne
reste un peu évasive elle n'est pas la
première à se faire passer pour Jeanne
d'Arc à l'époque d'autres femmes
affirment la Pucelle mais cette fois
c'est un peu différent plusieurs
personnes la reconnaissent et pas des
moindres il y a parmi elles d'anciens
compagnons d'armes ainsi que deux de ses
frères alors
comment douter l'histoire semble si vrai
qu'en 1439 la jeune femme est accueillie
en grande pompe à Orléans le fief de la
vraie Jeanne d'Arc elle y rencontre le
roi de France Charles VII en personne en
théorie il devrait bien se connaître
mais là coup de théâtre sans doute
convaincu que le roi ne sera pas dupe la
jeune femme se jette au pied du
souverain et à vous tout elle n'est pas
Jeanne d'Arc elle se prénomme Claude des
Armoises et demande grâce faut avouer à
moitié pardonné ouais pas cette fois car
en septembre 1440 la fausse Jeanne d'Arc
est condamnée à Paris pour usurpation
d'identité elle est même suspectée des
récits elle sera humiliée publiquement
au pilori mais s'en sortira mieux que la
vraie Jeanne d'Arc puisqu'elle échappe
au châtiment suprême je vous avais dit
que ces histoires étaient hallucinantes
je vous éparné et avec David on en a
beaucoup d'autres sous le coude alors si
vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas
à liker et à laisser des commentaires et
bien sûr à vous abonner à la chaîne si
ce n'est pas déjà fait allez à très
bientôt chers épicurieuses et épicurieux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]